wait has Chris died yet Chris hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to even more five nights at
Freddy's fan games now in the last
episode I did of this I mentioned that
there are tons and tons and tons of five
nights at Freddy's fan games and I
didn't even scratch the surface of the
good ones out there so I got a few more
here for you that I think you're gonna
like or maybe they're crap I hate whoa I
hate I broke it broke it Oh welcome to
five nights at McDonald's or something
Mac tonight five nights at Mack tonight
this is made by the same guy that made
of five nights at Treasure Island it's
shift tonight local McDonald's
restaurant in need of a security guard
to work night shifts through the week
due to odd behavior going on overnight
the McDonald's recently as well as
having a sous set of animatronic
characters that as well need to be
maintained salary includes 20 dollars
and fifty cents an hour not bad okay
that's definitely not one I have no idea
I can't make any testament to the
quality of this it is highly rated but
that might just be because it's
exceptionally me me I don't know we're
gonna find out Oh
Oh beautiful I love Mickey D's oh hi
hello friend 1 ding bing bong 1 may I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you should fix it we connected it around
the building in case of any emergency
but can take time to repeat DLF there is
also drive-through window of mrs.
holiday useful in Italy for as it is an
entrance advantage anyone who attempts
to break in so if you do happen to say
try activating some sastra the speaker
box and so on you know
what the [ __ ] is happening at this
McDonald's
and also God everything blinking in here
hurts my eyes what is happening and oh
no mr. Mack man you that's doing nothing
that's Nestor I don't know what that
does that seems to do nothing as well
and then we get the big purple monster
which was just like my phobia as a kid
I hate that [ __ ] purple monster okay
well we got a problem zero that's a big
problem
hi mister mmm eating tonight man it's
not working not working
yeah it's not working all right well we
got we got we got issues we've got we've
got issues okay well all right feel like
I'm gonna die soon probably how are you
here already
I don't know what it's broken is it
broken
it's broken okay my speakers are broken
okay
all right wait hang on hey great is
forget that Big Mac a drink down with
some diabetes that's very close where I
am I think I don't know for certain but
its problem I know it's a problem it's
very big gotta heat the ventilators okay
he's by the bathroom that's probably not
good so what if they moved okay he moved
he moved him he moved oh he moved where
did he move to harm in trouble oh no
he's not gone he's by the bath he's
inching closer he is legitimately
inching close let me for that great eh
Oh
yeah wait hey whoa let's talk okay you
wanna you want to run that by me again
you wanna you want to run that by me
again you wanna you want to run that by
me again
let's try that again I guess I do I was
fiddling diddling with the speaker and
nothing was Abaddon I was fiddled
diddlin as hard as I could fiddle diddle
three two one let's go that gray days
okay man I don't even remember what
McDonald's did the eat late commercial
[ __ ] thing how what's that other
[ __ ] do what no because I'm looking
at other I'm sorry if I'm looking at
other cameras is making you upset ma'am
I don't know I don't know you want from
me bro your eyes are not okay I've got
it broke again didn't it god damn it it
breaks too much god I love these themed
ones I love the theme doors look just
like for some reason it's like they want
to make McDonald scary why are you
moving I was telling you about that
great taste
fer that gray days go back go back
goddamnit he just left what I was giving
in that gray day supposed to do it it
told me that if something happens in
this this [ __ ] oak starts wandering I'm
supposed to have a great taste and other
than that just well [ __ ] me you know
just [ __ ] me I don't know there's
nothing to be done about it there's
nothing to be done nothing to be done
you
the active deactivate what did what I
hit sprinkle my butthole what am I
supposed to do great is great for that
girl further researches from flipple of
that TV from floor that it's going so
slow I I mean I thought oh hi Mac man
Mac man in the window driving no I'm
gonna die oh I'm not dead
I guess I'm not dead I thought I was
dead
turns out not dead
whoa that's problem I jump oh okay I get
it I understand now I get it I just got
it I'm supposed to do the floor that
gray days when he comes in cuz he can
come in at any point I understand it now
we are of an accord mr. Mack tonight I
now know what is everything that I am to
do someone buy me a button among you you
are you have come to make me Mack
tonight I do not like anything about
that sentence there is not a single word
in that sentence that I like come to
make tonight max okay but everything
else
not good I'm still a little worried I I
don't know if my theory is true or not
but now that I'm not so worried I think
that we're all gonna be okay and I
should be able to get through this Nigel
oh that's problem for the greatest it
worked who works it's for true it worked
it works it works okay where did he go I
know this is dangerous for me to just
look around for him oh he's up I saw him
he was creeping out on the stairs
which is fine yeah drive away is that
what they call it and wherever the hell
this person from oh happy fourth that
great taste
Bobby baby Bobby ever throw this morning
it's almost time for breakfast do not
come to make me Mac tonight because it's
almost morning and that's when breakfast
served and you don't have any place at
my breakfast
one of the hardest orders for McDonald's
to get for me and yes I'm gonna gripe
about a McDonald's order is when I want
a sausage McMuffin with egg whites
because every time I ask for that they
put white cheddar on it and I want the
regular American cheese because I hate
myself but they keep putting the white
cheddar on there with the egg whites for
some reason they won't though let those
two go separate they won't do Oh dad for
breakfast they won't do it I don't know
why I keep asking every time I'm like I
just want the egg whites with the
American cheese I don't like the taste
of the white cheddar I like white
cheddar by itself but this ain't at the
point come in come in ah Chris what can
I help you with well lately I've been
wanting to talk about my payment
situation what do you mean well life's
has been rather hard for my daughter and
I at the moment we've hardly any money
to get any food or such I was hoping for
maybe a raise just so I can make ends
meet well Chris I'd love to help but so
far even we have a low budget right now
and the McDonald's will be closed until
then closed what do you mean well seeing
how those mac tonight commercials
recently aired we got more attention
from the locals and seeing how the
people love the characters I thought I'd
order the play some fresh new
animatronic characters to keep the
customers entertained and to bring in
more people how does this include the
McDonald's being shut down until we have
to work on improvements new stages and
lighting this can take weeks because of
delivery and maintenance so I'm sorry
Chris you'll have to find some other job
to work at until this place is finished
but this was the only job I could get
nowhere else but hi
you'll have to see what you can do Chris
I'm sorry [ __ ] Chris uh-oh that's not
good oh is that the end is that just the
end hang on I want to see I want to see
what what else they got I'm not gonna
play too much more of this but I just
kind of want to see I'm curious you know
I'm not gonna do these to completion
don't expect the full playthrough of
five nights at McDonald's all right what
else you got for me huh oh let me know
tell me for true I'm president yes hello
Judy and Big Brother smaller than the
other animatronics no answer
Oh
I don't have any person from
intelligence
speaking of which
would you say press what press hash hash
brown I need to press the hash brown and
also why does the Hamburglar know what
the tempered I don't want to have
whatever you said I don't want it so the
hamburglar's the ham blur the Hamburglar
sorry excuse me I can't talk the
Hamburglar is also there for a second
there I thought they were talking about
this guy I don't even know what that
guy's name is but I hate I hate
everything about him you could just get
deactivated I don't like you oh wait
okay all right that's enough of that I
think that I think I've had enough of
that I think I had enough of this
hashtag not sponsored by McDonald's game
it's pretty good honestly it's pretty
good
did you just dab just see yeah all right
you know mr. Mack tonight I don't want I
don't want I don't want that no thank
you
so this next one is interesting because
I've actually already done a full
playthrough of five nights at 39s but as
you may know I played it stupidly high
all right geez shut up shut up so all
right
I've already played it which is just to
say that I played it very stupidly
because I played it and I didn't even
see half of the game because I for some
stupid reason didn't realize that there
was a flashlight in the camera to see 39
I thought it was just in the darkness
that my game was bugged but I played
through the whole game I was a [ __ ]
idiot so this is the anniversary edition
of this game
it's rerelease by the developer I just
wanted to play it a little bit because I
felt so bad [ __ ] you buddy yep man that
makes this mean I'm not gonna do a full
playthrough this
Frank so I mean I'm bored I could use
some company besides a plushie I
honestly didn't think you would turn up
well welcome to the adverts studio
bottom my TV because it's merely a
recolor of Freddy fazbear's pizza which
kind of exists in this universe I have
no idea how that makes [ __ ] sense you
know what I need a minute I'm getting a
big sense of deja vu here it feels like
the graphics have been touched up you
know one little lens flare here's some
Indian occlusion softer shadows and no
new textures
nice touch dev okay what is this a cash
grab you're lazy
oh listen to me I'm getting off track
sorry
see him you here to fight me yes no what
are you just gonna sit there in the
office and stare me the cameras yep Mike
you cannot handle this dick maybe in the
old universe you know what I'm gonna
shut up I'm saying too much I am NOT
coming off in chasing night I'm going to
do what I've been doing for the last 20
years all by myself randomly popping
into different rooms and if I happen to
pop in the office you are [ __ ] over me
you creep oh yeah so this is what I was
missing out on I didn't see literally
anything from the game I saw nothing
I saw absolutely dick Diddley his poses
and [ __ ] and I missed out on all of this
which is amazing you can play the whole
game without ever looking actually in
the cameras which are fascinating but
I'm not gonna do that
so this is the type of [ __ ] that
would go and you if the Fox in day shift
at Freddy's which is something that you
guys have wanted me to play still
debating that but we shall see
oh you look it up porn hey stop that get
off that computer hey spook I don't
remember that being a mechanic in the
last one I don't remember that being a
mechanic before okay all right okay I
don't know I need to spook him on the
computer well looks like I'm about to
die sorry I don't remember if you jump
scare me now all right so anyway that is
that was just a little bonus one it's
nice out not real oh it's not real it's
just a little bonus one now this one's
called fredbear and Friends reboot frame
rates a little off-kilter but hopefully
that smooths out once I get in the game
here this one's supposed to be like free
roam Jimmy chamois woody woody I don't
know what the arcade would be but let's
go into single-player now I don't I
don't know anything about these
particular five nights at Freddy's fan
games all I know is that they're highly
rated and probably either funny or scary
or a combination of the both
hello's calling so late why don't you
look mom dude do you know what time it
is
woke me up perfect time to visit my
place what do you mean by your place do
you remember the old restaurant I told
you about Chris please don't tell me
we're going there Oh what is it did you
become a chicken now what no right if it
wasn't for you I wouldn't be out of my
bed right now mmm yeah what are you 12
yes what are you chicken oh no my pride
oh I have to go now oh my god dark
applier letters all right let's see what
we got going on here I don't know why
Chris why what do you mean restaurant
that you told me about oh my god well I
mean I don't know about going there
anyway good the question is nothing but
ruins it's been abandoned for like 20
years or something I can't think of any
where were staying out then there then
why are you going
you cannot go if you this must be the
place I don't see how could you tell
it's an obscure grey building oh good
it's raining here we go then I guess
hello
squeaks Kwang is it oh hi Chris hey
Oh so what exactly are we doing good
question question no I don't think I
will what's the plan
mm-hmm okay this place is really dark
maybe trying to get the power back up
am I supposed to do that and see what's
behind the curtains and you Tom
you should check out the office
interesting why are we here why it's not
like we're treasure honoring at best
we're breaking and entering I'm a
goody-two-shoes I'm gonna rat you all
out oh hello no one here is horrible
a little bit expecting that
twenty-year-old restaurant yeah you know
that's not how buildings usually go
people don't just leave it abandoned in
the middle of the city for 20 years
also why is there a baby stroller why is
there a very dirty baby stroller here
mmm
I don't like this hello oh hi okay who's
very convinced oh yeah uh-huh
[Music]
yeah all right well I don't and I don't
know why I'm back but here we are
oh all right I think I'm supposed to
find the office and if this is the
general Oh God you are scary why are you
why are you in the middle of here hello
nope haven't found the office but I'm on
the way don't you worry your pretty
little head what do we have here this is
not the office hello hi it's not
generally the layout of the original
five nights at freddys so I'm not a
hundred percent sure work oh all right
this should be the office never mind it
is about power though hmm all right well
that doesn't sound like a good idea
your crosshair turns red when it hover
over an interactive object okay doesn't
seem to be working what the store still
works that's cool hmm all right easy
enough okay so that works and it's on
like a conditional timer oh okay
computer
it's a monitor doesn't seem to work
though sam james fridman friends is a
great place except for one thing the
main stars the animatronics those things
are just creepy look at Freddy he just
twists his body around his jaw moving up
and down mindlessly just look like all
right
Fox does just dangerous he almost took
my friends and an army of the others I
guess
but I do love spring Freddy he doesn't
really look creepy and he's probably the
most kid-friendly thing here
homely the old spring bonnie comes back
as well okay whatever you say a weird
random tape guy who another one that I
just compress into my boy all right
place to work place is kind of well
overcrowded most of the time customers
can never get to the arcade machines
mostly because of this one guy who's
always screaming you're messing with the
wrong Somali talking about his foxy
plushy like Jesus dude you're not the
only guy in the place and the kids are
always so annoying no matter what I had
a box of pizza for a customer nice dude
in some cutoff jeans they came over and
knocked me down with it I got so pissed
off and I couldn't do anything I swear
they'll get something coming to them
soon but hey the pay is good so I can't
really complain hmm he's taking a free
viewing of the show Oh what the [ __ ]
wait a minute I don't want a free
viewing of that
hi what the hell was that and why the
hell was that what are you eating pizza
what are you eating 20 year old pizza
you okay are you dead found it oh is it
not much it's broken monitor doors usual
stuff did you look around for some
papers no not really
why would I there's some really sketchy
stuff going on around here a bit more
about this sure okay yeah my sketchy he
wouldn't believe it anyway
oh whatever I'm just gonna go and
explore a bit more I guess yeah okay
yeah I mean we're here at 2 a.m. or at
least past midnight on your whims and
you're gonna well okay hi how are you
doing
disturbing yeah no joke okay well at
least the police the voice-acting knows
what they're talking about and the voice
acting is pretty good so I can't
complain about that alright let's hope
nothing else pops out at me like a
horror show was it here hmm I guess I'm
I have nothing to say about the chained
up door back there I'm just gonna assume
that everything's hunky-dory okay what
is this animatronic safety up at night
probably gonna like this how do you know
my name how do you know my name anyway
let me read that the animatronic for
acting up can you check out him for the
past few days we were getting complaints
about them acting very strangely
especially towards adults I don't think
the newer models are ready to perform
yet I'd rather have the older ones I'll
stay for some time at least until the
problems I'll be sure to check on spring
Freddy as he's happens to most issues
after a short amount of time performing
he becomes unresponsive started moving
on his own okay alright hey Chris Chris
Chris I found something
Chris crass Chris Oh
not enough okay God is demanding [ __ ]
oh here we go
mark there have been reports of a
disturbing and possibly armed man maybe
even to arms he has long hair is hunting
over dressed in a purple shirt blue
jeans and a baseball cap if you see this
man call the police immediately he's
dangerous and scaring our customers off
yeah okay that's enough for Chris
everything else I did wasn't enough for
Chris but that does weird that's enough
for Chris alright grass crashes okay all
right Chris quotes krokus Crabill oh
hello Richard Ashley where the hell are
you guys this isn't funny guys
Mike at all guys ashley richard crimps
oh um well I'll just wander back in
their face first hoping and praying that
something's gonna happen to me okay
Richard
get the hell out of here no I need to go
into here apparently hello well I don't
sound good at all um okay well I guess
y'all heed their advice I'll actually go
out of here only because I think that
that's where the game wants me to go so
that's where it's gonna progress oh my
god get out of here I got it oh no of
course yes I have to hide in the office
best idea I've ever hold answer me Chris
Chris
oh no Chris stress
Oh God I can't even go over there
there's an invisible wall all right it's
fine then I won't go after my friend
I'll run away like a little [ __ ] baby
oh well guess all my friends are dead
now I don't know what I need to do to
prevent my own death but here I go Chris
gracious Oh what oh [ __ ] me sorry my
apologies [ __ ]
oh well keep distance from Spring Bonnie
otherwise it's an instant game over
I kind of surmised that I kind of
investigated that on my own am I going
to the office oh my god
alright you know what that was a bad
idea that was one of those bad ideas I
had I thought I had a good idea that was
apparently a bad idea right Freddie
blocks always and will attack you if you
go hey let me learn then get love it's
alright here we go here we go let's do
this again bring a rag around alright
Wow okay wait has Chris died yet Chris
[Music]
was that foxy the end Oh clusters is
hiding in the fence at all times the
only way you can tell us about the wires
a hang-up then how can I get to the
office
woofle Fork I'm trying to close it I'm
trying to close it stop Chuck close it
close it close close it oh hey I
couldn't leave it was an eye Moo
definitely gonna be able to make it work
nope it no work okay it no work this no
work that no work can't go through here
well guessed em oh oh okay that doesn't
make the most sense put alright how
about it are you doing yeah I'm good one
alright yeah it's gone forever yeah just
gone just like that all gone
nightmares gonna fly away like
butterflies you'd be real it can't be
real seems pretty we'll both dead
Ashley where's Ashley uh-huh okay
all right I don't know if that's the
best idea you've ever had but no okay
let's go for that one normal hello hello
Robert sis please send help
please send help we're at the fredward
friends what the [ __ ] is going on
it okay okay okay I'm listening
great [ __ ] designing all my friends
are dead because of those insane hold up
you're telling me there's eight of these
things in the building the chicken this
is crazy this is insane
Freddy Fox tried a block
try to find its way to the power when he
gets there he will attempt to turn off
the punches attached to the ceiling
but activate the puppet slowly try to
the sefer but the most dangerous friend
always knows he's fast
listen God or what hell you mean like
that door so what do I do against mr.
Fred fair man Oh Oh a tablet device from
20 years ago
okay wait [ __ ] yeah I'm not gonna be
good yeah I can already tell I'm not
gonna be good brah I'm gonna be the
worst actually if you wanted to really
get together about oh my god how many
cutscenes are in this goddamn game I
want to play let me play what's up I
couldn't reach Mark I called him
multiple times but no answer so
unfortunately have to go in there
yourself oh hey what's wrong
the new animatronic models were acting
very strangely and aggressively as
described by our customers can you check
on them I don't want to use the older
models they're old enough dated
technology and they just don't have up
to this day all right I'll be there in
five great good luck what is this what
is that what does that have to do with
anything that I just did it who is that
I mean the letters were to somebody
named mark hood okay wait what am I did
I suddenly go in the past why I was just
trying to play I get think you want to
get this story out but I want to play a
[ __ ] game
sorry yeah I just have no idea why it
would suddenly jump back in time like
this I mean I know
gonna be relevant later but it seems
like odd because they just gave me
instructions on how to play the game and
avoid those animatronics and then it's
not put into practical application so
it's just like okay what am i doing
all right enough criticizing I'm not
sure what's wrong
hmm so manually turn them off and take a
look yeah
God disassembled them late at night for
some oh my nose
I'm bleeding now dick hole oh we all
right what else about our way out fast
okay and we're bit okay [ __ ] the battery
of course is when he question
what's out of the question you should
try and find a way to open the exit door
wait you're gonna for you to give me all
this exposition to stir it somehow find
a key look around all right I'm gonna
look what the [ __ ]
no I pressed escape fast okay hmm
yeah sounds like a good idea okay we're
finally get a good look around pick up
the back room key on the shelf okay okay
this could be useful uh-huh could be
useful and now I can go okay anybody
there Chris Cruz Cruz okay see I don't
know what the good and bad noises are
but we're finally in the game
I can finally play hooray oh god I
thought that was something completely
different not a [ __ ] happened here well
hell out of here where's your I could
explain to you what happened here
somebody was murdered horribly with a
hammer to the back for hiding this stall
hiding the bloody straw I want to go
with the bloody one okay good
hey let's forget about all that gameplay
mechanics that you taught me about let's
just hide in the stall the suits do that
ooh maybe it's a good antibiotic maybe
he'd be fine maybe I should just give it
a big hug oh it did not sound like it
was out of the way yet well okay I guess
we're done [ __ ] was that I think it was
an animatronic you know I don't want to
hear I don't want to go out on a limb
here but I'm pretty sure judging by the
clankity clank of its foot see Tootsie's
I think about about an animatronic all
right whatever let's keep going
all right now we're gonna play this now
we're playing the game all right cool
Oh hmm
well don't like that all right but it's
all right now we're gonna play yeah and
that's it game over everybody we are out
yes boy I don't feel like it was a good
idea to hide in here please please I beg
and pray oh well thumpy thump hmm
that didn't seem too good all right well
I thought you were the Heidi Heidi today
not the Heidi Heidi chase me type I
don't know how you open that door
okay I'm sorry whichever one of my
friends that was well sorry
thanks for the diversion though oh
that's [ __ ] go you put even where the
[ __ ] did it go oh well you stay away you
stay okay all right that don't make too
much sense yeah might be maybe a little
bit
I'm so [ __ ] done with this place yeah
I don't know I don't know I haven't even
started yet what about the other exit
the other exit you know in a place that
serve children you know some nice food
you'd think that there would be another
exit do it can I look okay look and see
okay he's still on the stage no one out
there
no on there down there all right the
coast he looks cleary oh it's time to
finally play the game let's play the
game oh oh that's not good okay well
that's bad or I guess I guess all rules
are on now right yeah oh [ __ ] well
that's problem hmm okay well we got that
in the way so we need to not go that way
oh oh oh okay he's coming up that way so
we just got to get around him and we got
to get to the other quote-unquote other
exit which I don't even know where that
would be there was another door on the
other side of like the employee area but
I don't know if that's what they're
calling the other exit also everybody
shut up I need to listen no what about
this isn't that another exit animatronic
control puppet control please no
all right fine then okay all right where
the hell would another exit be I don't
well that guy's an [ __ ] where would
another exit be I don't even know what
do you it doesn't make any sense
okay that's a lot of blood nope good
[ __ ] doors gone here too
yep okay he's so happy has happened me
to wonder that me to think how Richard
that musty came from somewhere around
the office uh-huh uh-huh let's go fast
Oh about that we got a clanking Clank on
route big problem um which way is it
coming
and why does clang Keys Clank sound
faster what was that about fredbear
being all like super death oh hi oh hi
okay
I hope there's nothing in my brain Oh
problem problem problem problem problem
okay never mind cutscene hello
oh hello is anybody there no it was it
was it may be useful okay why do you
know that whoa hey whoa let's talk about
their personal man it's just business we
oh it gets tips that fan word is dead in
the past what was the point man alright
anyway I'm gonna end this one here this
one is it's very heavy in the story and
that's not a bad thing that's not a bad
thing Isis I didn't know it was going
into it it's a little hindered by the
fact that it had so many cutscenes so
many cutscenes just broke up the speed
of playing the game so much then it
became this very stagger-step of I
didn't feel like I actually had any
control it's just a very like linear
rails go to and I hope that later on it
just lets you play but at the same time
it was very hard to get into I anyway
besides that we got another one here and
then I'm gonna play for you all right so
this is jolly one I did a full
playthrough of jolly 3 and it was
amazing so I kind of wanted to see what
the original jolly was like because I
never played it so without further after
the release of Circus babies pizza world
fast food restaurants were all of these
after five nights at Freddy's 4 sister
location was all these after this those
are recent then I'm gonna kiss not that
reason that was even 3 years ago now
alright however the CEO of jolly
entertainment said he will not prevail
this drop of attention to his
restaurants and that he will compete
with circus babies pizza world he
announced it's starting okay shouldn't
have been off in my own brain oh hey
always remember to check the window in
front of you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that would make the metal
[Music]
the building our doors and the
animatronics there decides to climb
through the vents to go down the
elevator is by the camera just which you
can put in the elevators there
the animatronic ignores the doors run
through walls and ceilings
stop him from getting away go over to 11
and it's one of why everybody goes brand
[Music]
you've got this 50 per Tilian things how
in the [ __ ] I never remember what the
goddamn elevator did what do you mean
seal the fence [ __ ] you I don't even
understand what when what is happening I
why is that a problem
I don't understand I can't even close
this damn thing I don't even know who's
at my door why are you such a problem
why are you problem okay anyway I'm
sorry oh all right
that's a noise ah okay I got turn that
off apparently right
understood I see where the gas mechanic
evolved from but also what in the flying
[ __ ]
okay well that's I there's oh hey that I
don't want you in there I think so I
guess I'll do that then I'm dead aren't
I aren't I I'm probably dead
good I can't go to anything else when
you're doing that okay I'm gonna stop
panicking like an [ __ ] and I'm gonna
try to look at is there even anybody on
this first floor yo hey that's a problem
I guess
okay wait no I don't want you on that
floor no wait you go away can't move I
can't move them okay you go here and
then you will there I think I don't know
man
this doesn't make any sense I think that
sucking my building power if I'm not
mistaken that's what's chocking up okay
someone was in the vents
[Music]
someone was I don't know the way that is
just you know to do with my time so yes
yep just got up that's what we got
[Music]
what's that what's that sound that's a
nice sound oh good I think I can open
the door baby yes I [ __ ] God as the
most insane first night I've ever been
on
- what's that sound
why is there jingle jangle music
happening why would why would you be
jingle Jeannot get off my goddamn floor
get off my floor oh of course
okay alright yes thank you
do I have visitor okay no I don't hey at
least I'm almost done I think maybe I
don't know if I've done anything right
but it feels good you're in there which
is good question mark I don't know where
anybody is what was that
I saw something right there I saw
something did you guys see something cuz
I thought I saw something I'm just gonna
close this door amphibole
cuz I got the extra power for it it's so
weird because I can see how they made
like elements from jolly three from this
like you can see the evolution that the
the the clock is only on this power
panel like you can see like the
maintenance where you can't change
anything while you're doing one specific
ssin so you're kind of committed to it -
fixing [ __ ] now the other things like
the ceiling and I don't even stand Oh
signals out
sure ah that sounded like a bad elevator
maneuver hey we made it
wait sure okay
I've set a loss okay here we go where
are we going now I don't even know what
I am I think I'm jollibee but we're
going on an adventure oh never mind
we're going all right here we go hello
where am i how am I gonna compete with
my competitors how can I make a cheaper
better animatronic oh goody goody
gumdrops where am I even going this
classic five nights at Freddy's 2 thing
who knew that this mechanic from five
nights at Freddy's 2 would well I don't
wanna this mechanic specifically this
what we're seeing right here this from
five nights at Freddy's 2 it's like it
permeated everything every other five
nights at Freddy's fan game that came
after this one incorporated this in some
way because this was so super cool this
was really unbelievably cool when it
happened in the main game just because
in like these games it is like an
incorporated part of the game but in the
other one it was a rarity random chance
could happen and that was what made it
so cool five nights at Freddy's 3 like
became part of it later because it was
like oh you know you have to get it to
get to lore in five nights at Freddy's 2
is like if you missed it you [ __ ]
missed it and you know it just wasn't
even part of it so that's what made it
so interesting
a box full of pawns in your offense yeah
that came from the ocean or Freight they
were bought from this place called
asbestos scan or something like that
yeah busy unpacking I'm building the
animatronics that we didn't have the
time to lift the boxes of spare parts in
the office
yeah there's parts on video speak of
hours
ever yeah he's the most memorable when
it comes to children I want to remind
you about the usage of the air vents and
the elevator you don't really need to
keep them soon hey here's an advice deal
with end up when you're too busy fixing
cam and Evans rotors that should work
well with the elevator too I'm gonna
just roll up and die I'm going to die
it's just a straight-up fact I'm gonna
die oh where did everybody go already
oh boy oh boy you get off my goddamn
floor you [ __ ] please no thank you no
thank you no thank you
well everything seems to be calm in the
intermediate stages of this but I'm
still gonna die all right
so it's about power management it's
about managing where they are it's about
not doing stupid [ __ ] so all of my
weaknesses I suppose fazbear's fright if
I remember correctly that was five
nights at Freddy's 3 so this takes place
after that like this is way way way down
the road way into the future and
thankfully it seems like this night is
being calm there might have been a bug
that was like making the okay nevermind
nevermind I spoke too soon and I'm an
[ __ ] [ __ ] me I should have taken
things
I took things for granted I thought it
was gonna be nice to be the whole
goddamn time it is not alright that's
fine
get oh oh oh bird
you got a sassy waddle to you I have a
funny feeling that you should not be oh
boy - - great - ah problem problem oh
that's also a problem okay so someone's
gonna be coming around the mountain when
she comes
that bird that bird is a friend of
problem for me before but for right now
that bird is okay and also we're in the
Frick frack Oh already in the vents you
stop right there is that good for me is
that what I needed - oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
how did you I seal do I she'll do that
you're right there is that not the same
[Music]
animal
hi hi you sassy waddling bird duck oh
that's a new sound that's okay that's
not good that is that's one of those
that's one of those not goods also
where's that bird where is that oh [ __ ]
okay that birds get real close so I need
to I don't know what I'm supposed to do
what oh wise I don't know what that is
what is that the elevator nope
awesome fine
yeah go away you sacks of crap don't
know what's good for you so go away five
eight nine yes it's a big day okay I got
it
man there's a lot to there's a lot to
manage but at least they're not throwing
it at me all the way now that's a good
learning curve now that's good game
design okay what other Horror Show do we
have the experience Oh woohoo excuse me
kids pardon moi pardon me
must step on head Schism more Jollibee
got a buzz off over here that this
doesn't seem okay something tells me
this should not a moving I mean I guess
that was the whole point I mean in the
middle of day they're supposed to
entertain what are you you horrible
monstrosity excuse you
all right well sayonara I'll just go up
and out of here because any part of this
no I don't want any part of this oh it's
okay I don't know if it is okay I'm
pretty sure it's it's anything but okay
yeah okay that's not all right fine I'll
just leave see ya oh hey okay admittedly
you know if you really think about it
the whole concept of animatronics just
walking around not cool even in broad
daylight not cool not cool that's what's
happened that's a shotgun to the face is
gonna happen all right
since the pretty active as the week
progresses
abroad mention when Joey enters in front
of the office and the door isn't closed
Johnny will clog the door you won't be
able to put it now that should be a
problem if you keep the door closed
never mind keeping the door closed when
you don't need it will drain your power
press that anyway good luck told you say
oh this ok whatever so I just got to be
smart about power
righty-ho and then I got a watch
oh he's gone oh well we're no no no no
don't go don't don't don't
how about you don't how about you how
about you don't you're already on that
okay you're already here just go away
that's an option
where did Jolley go ok that's problem
well gonna close I don't like the
screaming don't like the screaming
screaming is my least favorite part of
all of that screaming still happening
all I get oh boy okay well that's a
problem
can you hold boy okay this is a lot of
screaming Avenue and items I don't feel
like I feel like it's a conducive to a
good working environment oh hey all
righty then let's just send you back
Jollibee let's let's send you back down
now think I'll be jolly needs to be
anywhere near where I am boy I can check
the window in a while that's okay
problem problem solved no problem no
more there is a problem there's a
problem
no I'm dad Oh oops not after I was
paying too much attention to jollibee
staring at me in the face okay so that
is jolly the very first jolly still
pretty damn good
I mean jolly three was flippin amazing I
love that a lot it always topped by like
joy of creation just in terms of my
favorite fat fanat fan game but these
were pretty good so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know you
follow these down the comments below
I'll provide links to all these
especially to the one that was very
narrative-driven
if you want to play them for yourselves
check out the links all these are free
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]